welcome back to new rock stars what if
episode 7 had bring the party to earth
as an only child just looking for a good
time i mean makes sense aren't we all
and he still found jane and darcy but
didn't find any of the other avengers
and everyone in the universe seemed to
show up on earth like even the sovereign
i cannot get over the fact that those
gold people showed up for this party
good god the snobby golds anyway like
literally what is this a rick sanchez
party and in the end earth was saved
when thor's mama showed up or was it
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
going wrong with me today we have our
own party goddess herself jessica
clemens what's going on jess hey ready
to talk about the snobby golds and the
frosty blues
nice snappy golds and frosty big frosty
blues
don't get me started oh don't get me
started baby don't give me that
this ain't big question but i got
something bigger nope just keep going
edit that out no
keep it in okay keep it in okay and we
of course we got good friend of the show
and intergalactic dj supreme marina
masters what's going on stop yeah i'm a
dj for sure
i was in the episode in the back dj like
you're the you're the alternate in case
uh you know grandmaster gets you yes
risk gets like hurt she was actually in
the background doing the djing and he
was doing oh
okay she was the arms she was actually
the army
and of course host of the film's lost
first podcast and the guy at the party
who will definitely get a tattoo with
you it's eddie villenueva what's going
on
what is up guys i'm excited to be here
and this last episode probably has been
one of the more funner ones but i can't
wait to talk about it with you guys and
of course this episode of what if was
one big party until some gnarly looking
party crashers showed up at the very end
giving us our strongest to be continued
moment in the series yet so this moment
at the end brings us to our first topic
of today
why was the watcher surprise because if
he was supposed to be a step ahead of
knowing the consequences of a
character's actions why did ultravision
catch him off guard and like what will
be his response to ultravision are you
raising your hand teacher teacher
teacher teacher teacher teacher all
right sorry for the teacher sorry we got
it
up in the back what's going on jeff um i
think i think it's pretty clear that the
watcher was surprised oh sorry not an
offensive way but i think that
not an offensive way i think it's clear
that the watcher was surprised because
this ultravision wasn't from this
universe wasn't from party thor's
universe okay so i think because he is
always a step ahead and so he was like
they're gonna live happily ever after
who the hell is this and i think this is
leading up to even if it's a gang of big
bads for the um for the um
for the series of what if um that the
watcher will eventually have to step in
because these people are now just
jumping timelines and he's like i watch
everything but i am not going to allow
you guys to just jump and rule over
other people's timelines that's not what
we're doing right yeah so i think he was
surprised ultimately
not today
yeah not today
and
i was like i'm here for it go off
jeffree ride go off
but
i think ultimately they're not it's from
a different universe and they weren't
supposed to be showing up in this one
that's interesting okay yeah i think
jess is on to something as well because
one of the biggest things that you look
at with when it comes to marvel history
uh when we introduce because i'm i'm
pretty sure we all assume this is
ultravision i'm going to go back to the
comics and even during that time you
know ultravision was becoming a threat
to the mcu as a whole the mcu comic
universe and so they had to bring in
korvac because of the fact that they
were worried about what i think why he
was a surprise is that uh this
ultravision was a nexus being and
operating outside of that timeline it's
difficult to kind of pinpoint what is
going on and seeing as we're
incorporating a ton of nexus beings
that's the reason why it was such a
surprise
hopefully kind of along the same lines
as jess was saying they move into the
arena of him being the ultimate baddie
at the end of this season and we get all
the avengers from the previous what if
episodes to combat against this maybe
even getting a glimpse of uh korvac
michael korvac from the comics who is
the timekeepers have to actually pluck
him out of the timeline and place him
where ultravision is so that they can
combat against each other and michael
korvac defeats ultravision um that would
be a fun little twist but i think that's
kind of maybe the direction they were
thinking that'd be really cool i mean
now we're having not only the sorcerer
supreme in some sense of a way a nexus
being with the what if series but now we
have ultravision who may this may
confirm he is a nexus being ooh i really
like that because the i think there are
rumors that michael korvac will be
appearing in the marvels as the main
antagonist villain and it would make
sense um given that you know michael
korvac is this being all about cosmic
energy and you know
carol and spectrum that's their whole
deal cosmic energy floating computer
combating in space
seriously this floating computer that
loves cosmic energy it's the weirdest
thing in the comics go go look it up um
but no i really like that what what you
got marina all right mine's the dumbest
um
no don't say that mourinho i literally
are geniuses and why don't you be the
most badass one out of all of them she's
like well kevin feige told me yesterday
it's the strongest thing you can do and
most confident thing you can do coming
in and being like mine's the dumbest
top acceptance mine's dumb yeah that's
that's what i say every time though this
watcher is owatu right
and um
he's earth's uh watcher in particular
and by the way i can't i realize the
watchers that's always how they've
looked but i cannot separate it in my
brain if you guys have seen on instagram
the filter where it makes your head big
and the body is little and then people
pretend they're little kids oh yes
you know what i mean and now every time
i watch the show i cannot take jeffrey
wright seriously
because he looks like a bobble head and
he looks like he has that filter on and
i can't deal with it so he's actually at
home like all right and we're filming
some marvel
literally like you might as well that's
the proportions are identical i can't
okay so in the comics oatsu eventually
is punished for uh interfering with
earth's uh like events right for
interfering and actually taking action
we don't know in this series if this is
before or after that he's already been
punished so the rest of the watchers in
watcher world have now punished him and
he's been kicked out of watcher world
right and so part of being a watcher is
that you have access to the encyclopedia
universum right and so my theory is that
one of the consequences for him getting
booted
for interfering is that he doesn't have
access to that anymore in other words he
was plugged into the brain his big old
bobble head was plugged in oh
that's a good theory and they punish him
and he's now disconnected so he still
knows everything that he sees currently
but he can still get like surprised
because he doesn't have access to all
the knowledge in all of the other
watchers heads he's kind of working on
his own so it came in as a surprise and
because this is the first time he's been
like wait what
so maybe they punished him in between or
maybe he's working on his own this whole
time he now can get blindsided right
because he was straight up like wait
what
which was very lovely okay i do love
that i love that a lot because like we i
feel like we're starting to really go
into the concept of like you know like a
world mind because like the the nova
corps in the comics there is a world
mind the cree super intelligence supreme
intelligence sorry um that's a world
mind type like you know an amalgamation
of like all the cree minds put together
so like i think it'd be really
interesting to see like a watcher
world mind in the watcher world where
like they were all connected it's like
we're all omniscient we're sharing all
the stuff that we learned and then like
you know being like oh watch her want to
he [ __ ] up he's out of here you don't
get the the sweet info you get your own
[ __ ] right now he's like whatever i'm on
a tv show
stupid thing i have an agent with kevin
bikey so whatever
yeah yeah i don't need you daddy yeah i
don't need you
but now that he's kicked out he has more
motivation to intervene right so in the
future of the series he might be way
more likely like jessica was saying i
think like now he's gonna start getting
involved because he i mean but right now
he's like well if i'm kicked out i'm
kicked out i might as well do whatever i
want i also like the idea of doctor
strange since he's able to see him being
like what happens next really i don't
know i was disconnected
it's like that it's like unveiling the
wizard of oz to just be a man behind the
curtains like why can't you do half the
[ __ ] you think you can do and it's like
i don't know they kicked me out yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
sorry wrong number
these are all really great theories i
love them all
um i'm going to give
the ladies 2 000 points each for their
amazing theories but i've got to give it
to eddie v
for 3 000 points with 3 000 points for
eddie v because my man brought up
michael corbin oh you love him 3 000. i
love him 3 000. um i should have
announced that up top
it's going to be a very biased episode
[Laughter]
it's true we have a twitter relationship
yeah
we do so what are your guys's thoughts
then on the idea that maybe at that
point when owatu actually was surprised
we learned from the loki tv show that at
that point in time at the end of the
serie or at the end of the season that
once they cross that threshold as as
they they mentioned that anything was
possible what if at that point in the
series because time is relative that at
that point in the series it kind of runs
parallel with what was going on in the
loki series and at that moment that the
moment that uh he died
that's the point that to where he was
like oh wait what's going on now oh wow
it could have i think it could line up
for every universe that way because it's
like that's how i'm thinking or i don't
and correct me if i'm wrong but i assume
that's what's happening with like all
the other series that's currently going
on like that
boom is like across the globe happening
at the same time so it wouldn't surprise
me if the watchers just like oh
everything's happening at once yeah
everything's going on also it would be
gr
for just like
tangential like connection it would be a
good idea to do that so if the writers
are listening to this episode of
brokenness what do you mean yes steal
eddie's idea yeah what do you mean if
yeah
michael waldron yeah michael waldron do
you have any kind of say mt you're
friends with him tell him there you go
no i really like that eddie because like
in as established in loki there is the
possibility of timelines crossing and
you know universe is intersecting so
like there could be a chance that we're
seeing that here with you know ultron
vision crossing over with into this new
reality but chances are he's probably
doing that as an extension of the space
stones powers that we see at the
beginning of the season because we
learned that the red skull can open up a
portal to different dimensions with the
space stone like that's just so power
that we just didn't know that until now
yeah but i do like the idea of you know
the incursions which is a local term
happening um in that moment but anyway
good eddie good stuff good stuff yeah
that's nice good stuff and that's why i
love you three thousand oh we all do but
we've got some theories about why loki
was big and blue this episode but before
we do head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com because they have
not one but two shanxi inspired shirt
designs there's the latest obsession
shirt the great protector and a shirt
with the lovable furball morris on it
and you can get a great discount when
you buy both at the same time because we
have the technology to do so and you'll
be getting yourself two cool shirts and
helping support new rockstars and all
the content that we make but we also
want to thank simply safe simply safes
just launched their new wireless outdoor
security camera the system of the us
news and world report names the best
home security system of 2021 just got
even better this brand new outdoor
security camera is engineered with all
the advanced tech and security features
you want and needs to keep you and your
family safe it has an ultra wide 140
degree field of view 1080p hd resolution
and an eight times zoom not seven seven
is in the past we are in the eight times
zoom territory that means you can zoom
in and clearly see images you can
clearly see things like faces and
license plates and it has a built-in
spotlight with color night vision it is
super simple to set up and usually just
takes minutes for all that minutes crazy
it has an easy to remove rechargeable
battery it can go anywhere on your
property if you got a big property don't
even worry about it and the camera
integrates with your simply safe home
security system so that every door
window room and outdoor space
protected all of it and we actually have
a simply safe system in the office and a
few new rockstar staffers have systems
in their homes and we love how easy that
they are to install and to use so if you
try to show up we'll know that you're
coming we'll beat you with the baseball
bat just kidding don't do that we won't
do that we're not by the people so to
learn more about the exciting new simply
safe wireless outdoor security camera
visit simplysafe.com
rogue and what's more simply safe is
celebrating this new camera by offering
20 off your entire new system and the
first month of monitoring service for
free when you enroll in interactive
monitoring again that is simply safe dot
com slash rogue and also we want to
thank bespoke post because this fall
bespoke post is here with a new seasonal
lineup of box of awesome collections and
bespoke post partners with small
businesses to bring you the most unique
goods every month some cool boxes we've
enjoyed in the past had the supplies to
barrel age whiskey or to have an awesome
picnic so no matter what you're into box
of awesome has you covered from autumn
craft beers to camping gear essentials
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life and they even have a
box with everything you need to make an
awesome jack-o-lantern and impress the
neighbors or scare the children
hopefully the second part to get started
take the quiz at boxing awesome.com and
your answers help them pick the right
box of awesome for you and they release
new boxes every month across a ton of
different categories and it's free to
sign up and you can skip a month or
cancel any time that's the versatility
that box of awesome does and each box
costs only 45 bucks but has over 70
dollars worth of gear inside plus with
each box of awesome you're supporting
small businesses 90 of everything that
comes in your box of awesome is from a
small up-and-coming brand so please get
20 percent off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
and enter the code rogue at checkout
that is box of awesome.com code rogue
for 20 off your first box and we also
want to thank hawthorne upgrade your
grooming routine with hawthorne hotham
is a premium men's grooming brand that
makes it easy to be your best with skin
care and hair care essentials that work
for you as an individual to make things
simple they built a quiz based on data
from thousands of customers to recommend
products for your body chemistry skin
type hair type and lifestyle and it will
recommend face cleansers moisturizers
cologne and all the other ingredients
for a great routine so to get started
build your personal profile by taking
hawthorne's quiz they ask things like
how often you shave or if you prefer bar
soap or body wash and it's really quick
and easy and at the end of the quiz
you'll view customized products tailored
to your body hair skin and lifestyle and
folks that knew rockstars use their
products with off-screen producer zach
swearing by hawthorne deodorant and
cologne and hawthorne stands by other
customers so if you're not completely
satisfied they'll retail your products
for free based on your feedback and pay
for the shipping so there's truly no
risk so elevate your personal care today
by taking hawthorne's quiz go to
hawthorne.com and use promo code rogue
to get 10 off your first purchase that's
h-a-w t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o
promo code rogue hawthorne.co
not com promo code rogue so moving on to
our second topic of the show how the
hell did loki become a fully fledged
frost giant because we've always been
under the assumption that loki was a
frost giant runt but this loki was
definitely no runt was was this like
just a quirk of this timeline or would
this have always happened if he was left
with his people also
uh does loki does loki just looking f i
think
so so loki is a run right and and so my
theory is this timeline he is a runt but
in this universe he you know um you know
in real life when you get bullied when
you're a kid sometimes it's what makes
you funny oh yeah that's what this
explains my entire this explains my
entire life too deep marina
39 of mine too but like this is what
happens it's kind of a superpower that
emerges when you get bullied as a kid as
you're like i'll use humor to deflect it
which is you know welcome to my life so
if you're among friends uh and this is
kind of the same thing so like he was a
runt he got bullied like all the other
frost giants just like massively
mercilessly bullied him
from
like prepubescence but then when he like
got when he what is it called like got
testosterone right puberty
yeah puberty and he turned into a
40-foot tall uh giant he was it was he
was fueled by the energy that comes from
uh like having to deal with kids
bullying you and that's why he's so
clever and funny and that's why he's the
leader now at the front of the pack
because he had to deal with all that
growing up and so he's funny good
looking uh 40 foot feet tall and that so
he
definitely like for sure
because he's built all that character as
a kid i but i do i slightly do agree
with marina in that take i think so if
we go back to the first thor movie and
we see odin turning loki into what looks
like just an asgardian from what he
normally was
i think he's been living his entire life
this is rogue theory you guys so keep
that in mind he's living his life to
for the just the love and acceptance
from odin he wants nothing more than to
be just as good in odin's eye as thor is
right so i think not only like the magic
that odin did use on loki to turn him
into an asgardian stunted him from
turning into what a full-fledged frost
giant would be i think he just like was
so preoccupied with being the chosen one
kind of like how like bullying makes you
this it's like he's been stunted like
emotionally and physically because he's
been trying so hard to get odin's uh
just acceptance and so now that he
doesn't have to get odin's acceptance in
this universe i think he's just a
full-fledged frost giant and he's never
had to be second best for anything he's
always been welcomed amongst his people
so he has not he doesn't he didn't have
that magic and he didn't have to have to
get that acceptance from his father
because he had all these frost giants
that were all equally just like hey we
love you just the way you are you don't
have to match wits with thor the god of
thunder here we're all just frost giants
my dude so i think he's just incredibly
like lucky in this universe and just
amongst people of his kind that's such a
great like we need
strings underneath that with jess just
said so that way we can you know wow the
power of love i feel like i feel like
kind of going in and slightly the
opposite direction of jess i think
in in the terms of him being on with the
frost drones him being a small runt as a
baby i feel like because we don't know a
lot about how they raise their kids over
there i kind of get this like kind of
idea this this vibe that they're kind of
like the spartans like from 300 where
they train their kids up to be like
vicious and battle some and warriors and
i feel like
him having gone through all that
helped him to become much bigger than
what we see him in our in the normal
universe but also at the same time uh we
are
also still under the idea that there is
a you know norse mythology that is truth
there and if there is a thor and a free
frigate and if there is an odin then
there has to be a loki and i feel like
there has to be some sense of maybe part
of that magic that makes him
the trickster god or makes him that
infamous
god of mischief
there had to have been something that
maybe kind of imparts in him that where
he doesn't have to fully focus his
energy on magic but maybe it's the
energy in his strength or something like
that maybe that's kind of the making up
for on that side um because there has to
still be something according to like the
whole mythos of loki in midgard's you
know theology or ideology or whatever
and and making him being that cosmic
incredible being so no matter what
universe he's in he's always special do
we know if the frost giants because the
dad odin wanted peace amongst the
kingdoms or at least he said that's why
he took loki was to get peace from to
make everybody wholesome but i'm like
you don't steal a child you do that yeah
um you know
even though the child was abandoned most
of the time you know yeah most of the
time it didn't work it didn't work for
gomorrah yeah it doesn't work here
like stop trying to say what's with mcu
stealing alien children
that's so great
yeah the adoption process is just too
annoying it's too much too much kill the
child you might as well just destroy the
people and take their children that
one's nice should we take that one just
take that one no one's around yeah
things over like picking the right
watermelon
this one's firm
there you go yes
i think his mischievous would help him
still with the people with the frost
giants um and just in like war and
anything like that but also i think his
mischievous would still be there and
that's why he is the leader of the pack
of frost giants when he shows up to the
party like it's like the other frost
giants are like damn we ain't as sneaky
as you like you know we don't need to be
that sneaky anymore my dude they didn't
take you they brought you back he's just
like nah i'm still yeah i'm still loki
um so i guess it's not really a question
i think it's more of like and
i think
that that is very a right theory and
that would make sense why we still have
loki i can't wait till we go back into
the loki series and see frost giant loki
oh my god yeah he has to make a cameo he
has to make a cameo now now he's canon
and i'm gonna but i do have a i do have
an interesting question here so because
we know that you know this loki has some
type of relationship with thor uh we
could also assume that he probably had a
relationship with frigga even though
that wasn't exactly his mom so do you
think that this loki has some type of
knowledge of magic because he
technically has like two
well i don't know if he has his frost
giant moms but he has two sets of
parents so like maybe frigga taught him
magic and taught him the magic that he
needed to grow himself big but he's not
really really big so do you think that
loki's tricking all of his friends he
could easily learn magic because think
about it like every time your friend
came over after school to like eat pizza
or do homework or whatever you're just
like hanging out and the mom's like
knocks on the door and it's like do you
guys want hot cocoa or whatever and she
could just like knock on the door and be
like you guys want to learn magic and
then he just
you know you guys want to learn a spell
i think
this loki could learn magic but it show
it would choose not to
um just as we have party thor where it's
like this is a thor that doesn't care
about yeah yeah i feel like loki would
still be the same way he was the first
one to be like i'm not staying at this
party he's like that sounds like your
mother to you like that's not my mama
yeah so i think i think he he has the
opportunity to he chooses not to he's
living just a relaxed lifestyle as much
as uh the prince
thor is and i think the piggyback on
jess's idea of you know him not needing
to have that uh special attention from
his dad he doesn't need to have
something that makes him so unique like
the magic that he has a connection with
frigga to where you know not learning
magic he's just happy in the way he is
naturally because to be quite honest
when he says that whole thing like you
know purpose or he says something to the
effect that kind of mimics his you know
glorious purpose statement in towards
the tail end of this uh episode and it's
like okay he doesn't he doesn't care
about gloria's purpose he just wants to
be he just is happy which which is a
unique side of loki that we haven't seen
in the mcu it's so much better it's so
it's so like it's so sweet and lovely
it's like i hate party thor but i like
party like
the only universe yeah he just like is
so happy and content right it's it was
so nice to see the brothers bond and
just be like we love each other
like i love you loki i'm like this is
what i wanted this is what we all wanted
to see oh they needed to not be brothers
to get that world
even in the end even when like thor's
pleading with him to say he's like oh
it's not my mom see you thor
the next time and it's like the
equivalent to how we see loki in our
universe how he's just like but it's a
bigger disaster like when he attacked
new york it's just like yeah we'll [ __ ]
you it's like he has the same he has the
same like mindset it's just a such a
lower form of just like helping you
clean up this mess yeah
like
all right deuces like i'm leaving yeah
he's like let's bounce frost boys
[Laughter]
really quick because i i know we didn't
there wasn't a lot that gave you know
credence to it but there was in the loki
series do we feel like this loki
is fluid
dude
rager loki is absolutely
everything
well these were all excellent responses
but i'm going to give
2 000 points to eddie for his response 3
000 points to marina for her response
but four thousand points to jess for her
addition to marinas
so that brings us to a number that i
can't calculate with my small brain but
before we continue on to our rogue
question let's thank honey for
sponsoring this video we all shop online
we've all seen that promo code field
taunt us at checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is a free
browser extension that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart and honey
supports over 30 000 stores online from
gaming to popular fashion brands and
food delivery and when you check out
from one of your favorite sites the
honey button drops down and all you have
to do is click apply coupons and if
honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop at new rockstars
producer brandon has used honey to save
18 on a birthday gift for his nephew and
producer zach saved 11
on a board game what nice men and honey
has found it's over 17 million members
over 2 billion dollars in savings if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on some free
savings and it's literally free and
installs within seconds and by getting
it you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting new rockstars because this
type of stuff really does help us out so
get honey for free at jointhoney.com
rogue theory that is jointhoney.com
rogue theory all right gang you guys
ready for this real question well for
this road question we've got a title for
the next installment of the fantastic
beasts franchise in the wizarding world
cinematic universe it's fantastic beasts
the secrets of dumbledore so pitch me
your rogueis theories on what
dumbledore's secrets might actually be i
i feel like the secret probably i mean
in all good fun yeah i mean
there's really some semblance of of
information i believe someone had said
at one point in time that dumbledore is
actually you know bi but also in
seriousness like the
secrets probably have to do with more
than likely the the finding of the elder
wand and recognizing you know the the
different uh deathly hallows and having
them on hand in order for him to defeat
grindelwald when they do that final
battle
i know there's still like what five
movies in this series that they're
talking about
so this is what movie three yeah this is
the third this is the third i watched
the second one first
and i was like
why are there this is horrible writing
they already established who these
friendships are like and i am so
confused and then someone was like
jessica that's the second one so i've
never seen the first one
i saw the sequel the title
i wish they would just call them
one or two one or two you don't need to
come up with a crazy ass title and i
assume it's the first one yeah and i'm
doing that
just saying
oh my god thank you and so i'm so
confused in the order and then i watched
the second one and i was so confused
when johnny depp showed up because i was
like he just showed up in the last 10
minutes spoiler either way so funny all
right so i'm going to take this the not
real route also
sorry not sorry jk rowling can
yeah yeah so i think the plot of this is
dumbledore's secret is that he's
actually hermione's father
because a genius makes a genius and
she's still
um
she's still mud bloodish so i'm allowed
to say it because me too
and so
i'm just saying me too
and so i think he's the wizard and
her mom is just a normal lawyer
no what if what if dumbledore is yen sid
from the whole fantasia through that
fantasia 3000 4000 2000 uh where mickey
mouse mickey mouse is
like the master
first off mt you don't get points for
your theory i'm giving myself ten
thousand points for that yeah i win
hey
well i think i'm going to give
the rogue points
3 000 rogue points to jess for that
hermione's dad yeah because i think
that's just super rogue i would love to
see
uh like just secretly dumbledore being
your father yeah that's why we tolerate
you that's why everyone just tolerates
your voice
dumbledore immediately ran away april
dumbledore immediately dipped out he
went oh [ __ ] i'm a wizard but i'll send
her this invitation to my school
that's why he uh that's why he gave her
the time turner like this is all i can
do for you i don't have child support
right
take this damn take this damn time clock
and don't go farther back to see me hook
up with your mom tell your mom stop
sending me letters take this time turner
maybe you can stop me i can make this
joke because i have a single mom
it's okay
okay i think this makes jess our winner
for today
episode
congratulations to jess
you are
the queen of today i want to thank all
of you beautiful people for joining me
on this episode you can follow all these
beautiful people on their various
twitters jess at lulu clemens marina
marina masters right yep and eddie at
philosophy 101 please follow all their
stuff because they're all doing amazing
things and we love supporting our
beautiful friends of new rock stars but
more importantly you can do a lot more
importantly
um
more worthy than my friends
and of course you can support our
channel by checking out all of our merch
inspired by shanghi and all of our cool
nerd stuff at newrockstarsmerch.com
thank you all so so much for watching
and we will see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you